Ted, Deker, congratulations.
Your work has secured your place
in the "Forged in Fire" final.
When you arrived here,
you forged a signature
blade of your own design.
Now we're sending
you home to forge
an iconic weapon from history--
the tabar.
It's not a sword.
The tabar is a
battle ax originating
from Persia, Armenia, India,
and surrounding cultures.
Usually made entirely of metal,
it has a strongly curved blade
and a hammerhead
pole that was often
decorated with inscriptions.
The light metallic handle
is what makes the ax
unique and durable in battle.
During the 17th
and 18th centuries,
the tabar was a standard
weapon of the mountain
warriors of India, Afghanistan,
and what is now Pakistan.
With its double edged
blade and piercing spike,
it was an unrelenting
weapon of war.
This fierce weapon is featured
in the iconic film series
"The Lord of the Rings."
You will have five
days at your home
forge to complete your work.
At the end of five
days, you will
return and present your
tabar to our panel of judges.
Only after they've submitted
those weapons to a series
of brutal and dynamic
tests will they
declare one of you the
"Forged in Fire" champion
and the recipient
of a $10,000 check.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
My name is Ted Thompson.
I split my time between
knife making and tattooing.
Been a knife fanatic
my whole life,
and I just started
blacksmithing to see if I could.
Today, I'm going to
work on the handle.
There's a lot to think
about on getting everything
put together the right way.
Right now it's just a really,
really long eye poker.
I decided to make an
asset out of an eight
pound sledgehammer head.
It's a very good,
high impact steel.
I want to be able to chop a
car in half with this thing.
So-- I'm going to do an
asymmetrical double headed.
One blade's going to be a little
bit heavier than the other.
I'm [inaudible] the
metal so it spread
wide so I can start building
the beards of the blade.
Awesome.
Cool profile too.
I don't have a forge big enough
to fit the ax fully assembled.
So I used the front of the
forge and my cutting torch
and got it up to
critical [inaudible]..
And I quenched one side
and then the other.
Sweet.
Yep, she's hard.
It'll be ready to go.
I'm Deker.
I work as a computer
security consultant.
Blacksmithing and knife
making is sort of a sideline
that I do as a little
bit of therapy.
Planning on doing some pattern
rolling for this project.
If it's worth making, it's
worth making in Damascus.
This piece here is going
to turn into a long bar
of steel similar to this.
That'll then get
cut up into sections
so I can stack multiple layers
together in a billet to weld.
Time to get this steel starting
to look less like a lump
of stuff and more like an ax.
Inside the mind of a madman.
I'm going into the press to
do the very first [inaudible]
operation.
Defining moment.
I start to squish.
And just that right there
probably saved me 45 minutes.
Definitely a little
more sexy than what
I left with yesterday.
Now I've got the
spike in the forge.
I've got to get that drawn out.
Good gravy.
This spike is going to
make us heavier than hell.
I'm behind what I had set
myself for a schedule.
I've got a lot to
figure out, and I've
still got a lot to do tomorrow.
I certainly hope
nothing goes wrong,
but failure is not an option.
Let's go kill something.
Sweet.
That's done.
Come hell or high
water, that's it.
Bladesmiths, this
is the kill test.
The tabar's three
sharp sides allows
for three times the chances
of killing an opponent
in the heat of battle.
To test the lethality and
function of your weapon,
I will test all three
sides by chopping
at this animal carcass.
Ted, you're up.
Are you ready.
Heck yeah.
Let's do this.
Well, Ted, the
design of your blade
really digs into the carcass.
The hooks grabs
everything that's in there
and rips it right out.
Balance is a little
bit heavy, but it
will do a lot of destruction.
This weapon, sir, will kill.
Awesome.
Good job, sir.
Thank you.
Deker, it's your turn.
You ready?
Let's cut some bacon, Doug.
Let's do this.
Yes.
Well, Deker, your
edges are very sharp.
As you can see what it
did, it pretty much went
to cut all the way through.
The feel, though, is a little
bit rounded for the handle.
But nonetheless, it's light.
So I can generate more
power to control it.
This is a weapon that will kill.
Good job, sir.
Thank you.
I'm going to pass things
off to Dave for the next test.
All right, gentlemen.
It's time for the strength test.
Ted, you're up.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
All right.
All right, 3, 2, 1, engaging.
You put a really good
crease in the shield,
and that's a heck of a chop
you just chopped in in hardened
oak of this barrel.
A little bit of a roll
right up here on this edge
that hit the shield.
And the shaft of the ax
looks perfectly straight.
Didn't flex at all.
Well done.
Thank you.
All right, Deker.
You're up.
Let's tap a keg.
All right, 3, 2, 1, engage.
Son of a bitch.
Well, Deker,
your spike sheared
off right at that rivet point.
Yep.
You put a good
crease in the shield.
[inaudible] you put a
good cut in the barrel.
The edge of the ax here
that hit the barrel,
you just see a little
coloration, some shiny spots.
The side that hit the shield,
doesn't look like any damage
at all.
But that spike coming off--
well, that's a problem.
At the moment when that
spike fell, my heart just sank.
Gentlemen, you both put in
a lot of work on your tabars.
But in this arena, there can
only be one "Forged in Fire"
champion.
Ted, you are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Deker, your weapon
did not make the cut.
Congratulations.
[inaudible]
Ted, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion
and will be receiving
a check for $10,000.
Good job.
Awesome.
Thank you.
I joined this
competition to see if I
had what it took
to make a better
weapon than three other guys.
And I did it.
And that makes me happy.
Props for putting
"Forged in Fire--"
- Yeah.
- --on your blade.
And Persian around here
says "caution-- sharp edge."
Nice touch.
When I'm working with a
bunch of guys I really respect,
they're going to push
the quality that I do.
It pushed me a lot.
That's what I enjoyed about it.